balsa glax is going to be backing our
screens but will it be a hard reboot a
soft reboot or a continuation story
welcome to sidetrack your sci-fi tv a
movie channel
[Music]
so in collider there's been a couple of
interviews recently for the new
executive producer and showrunner of the
new tv series the battlestar galactica
and the guy that's making the new movie
simon kinberg is writing and producing
the new battlestar galactica film
and sam esmail is going to be producing
the new tv series for the peacock
network in america
hopefully it'll be on a regional network
over here in the uk and we can actually
watch the damn thing but let's hope
fingers crossed
but what do we actually know about these
two projects well they've both been in
production for quite some time actually
more than two years now obviously with
covid though everything's been moving
into snail's pace
before these two big interviews though
in the last month we didn't really know
a great deal about the storyline and
production and to be honest we still
don't know massive amounts about what is
planned for the tv series but what we do
know is that the movie that will be in
our cinemas at some time maybe towards
the end of 2023 is going to be an
adaptation a remake if you like of the
original 1978 battlestar galactica film
simon kingbook says the
second draft of the script is complete
everybody's happy with it they're now
looking for a director to take the helm
and they're hoping for production to
start in the next eight to nine months
with hopefully release date by christmas
2023
now him saying this is a adaptation of
the original 1978 movie basically means
it's a remake right it's going to be a
big screen remake of the original
battlestar galactica story we're hitting
a bit of a snag because of what sam
esmail has said about the tv series
he spoke to roland d moore he wanted to
get his blessing and did they talked at
length and what the new series was going
to be about and what his focuses could
be and roland d moore was concerned that
this show would trample on
his tv series baltimore galactica has
only been off our screens just over a
decade it's not something that is
distant in the past and i have to say
baltha galactica was a massive success
personally i preferred the mini series
the basically the mini series is what's
going to be remade in the movie but i
prefer the mini series the series
got a bit boring for me i have to admit
i won't lie but i come back to it again
and again and it's one of those two
series that was so beautifully made
and the story was so intriguing and so
twisty that it's one of those shows you
can watch again and again and again and
you always know when you're making a
really good show like roland d moore did
when other shows tried to copy it
stargate universe what were you thinking
but that's where the snag comes along
the tv show will not be a reboot it's a
continuation a new story within the
battlestar galactica universe he has
promised roland d moore that he won't do
anything that'll trample on or peel over
cannon that we've already got within the
tv series the problem comes that simon
kinberg has been talking about how
closely related the movie and the tv
series is
they've been talking about how much
they've been talking to each other
making sure that the movie and the tv
series influence each other
he has said very clearly that these two
projects do exist within the same
universe
so in that case we are getting a hard
reboot or a an adaptation of the
original 1978 movie and a tv series that
still respects the tv series from a
decade ago
so
where do those two things marry up
well
they're remaking basically the mini
series and the 1978 movie the
introduction of the cylons them
returning home the battle that then
happened and the escape of the
battlestar galactica
that is being remade but in the tv
series that is strongly linked and
intertwined and influenced by that
project
isn't a reboot
is going to be a continuation of a story
somehow related to both
so what does that mean for the tv series
is it a reboot is it an adaptation is it
respectful is it going to be trapped
somewhere in the middle
that is what worries me that
an identity of a tv show is always
really really important a tv show needs
to know what it is
and in this case i think if they're
trying to compromise between two
projects they don't want to ruin roland
d moore's project and they don't want to
maybe annoy fans by saying well this is
a hard reboot but at the same time their
influence and exists within the same
universe as a complete hard reboot i do
struggle with that a little bit it seems
that this movie is going to try to sit
on the fence
but at the end of the day we live in a
reboot society everything has to be
rebooted remade re-shot
there seems to be nothing new coming on
our tv screens definitely not in 2022.
why is that though why does everything
have to be remade and re-shot at the end
of the day this project by simon kinberg
is supposed to be a new story
existing within the battlestar galactica
universe so why does it have to sit
within the ballista galactic universe
why can't it just be a new thing a new
project on its own
well it all comes down to us
and clicks on the internet and things
like this at the end of the day you and
me are more likely to sit down and watch
a show that's related to even loosely to
a show we loved already than we are to
sit down and watch something that's
brand new
we're going to give our
hard earned precious time over to a tv
show we want to already feel connected
to before we even sit down
so
that leaves tv channels and hollywood in
a really difficult position
do they risk something new do they risk
something that you might not watch
or do they rehash something that you've
already watched
and that's always going to be the
problem and it's really is why 2022 and
2023 really are the years of the reboots
so what do you think guys battlestar
galactica you're excited for the movie
for one and then a tv series that will
not for once peel over cannon is this a
tv series that you want to see back on
our screens are there more stories
within this universe to tell
and if you are new to the channel please
like subscribe hit that bell
notification really helps us out you can
join the channel for a small fee each
month help me to create more contract
and become a sidetracker supporting the
channel you can also join us on facebook
there's a link in the description
please as always guys stay safe
i'll see